today we are going to talk about
differential gene expression analysis
and biological annotation pipelines
there are a number of methods and
algorithms that can be applied to
scrutinize the significant genes from
the rna expression data
depending on whether the data is
normalized or not these methods can be
applied for instance if data follows
normal distribution we can use various
types of t-test methods including welch
method wilcoxon etc
and if the data is non-normalized that
is it contains the raw rate count values
we can apply algorithms like dseg desect
2 and hr
thus depending upon the data type one
can choose a method in the previous
lesson we already talked about how we
can apply the t-test and how we can
extend the rnseq pipeline to
differential expression pipeline
now let's learn how we can apply the
desector pipeline and perform enrichment
and gsea analysis when we have a gene
expression in the form of raw count or
rate count values
the first step is to perform the
differential expression analysis for
that we need to select the differential
expression option under the data mining
section on the t bioinfo server
after clicking on the differential
expression option you will be directed
to the file upload interface where you
need to click on the data upload button
to upload your file
please make sure that your data must be
a read count values or raw counts
it should be containing the ids written
in the first row or the first column
only
also make sure there should be no blank
line and the end of your file and also
there are no duplicates in genes in your
data
after data upload make sure to drag the
samples into groups
it is important to remember what was
your group b
since when you interpret your results it
would be with respect to group b samples
for instance whether genes are
upregulated or downregulated in group b
thus it is recommended that you should
drag control samples in group a
and test condition under study samples
in group b
let's take forward all the er positive
samples in group a
and triple negative in group b
now click on the start button to build
the pipeline
next to perform differential gene
expression click on the desector module
or you can also choose the hr
here we are using the desecto module
so by clicking on desect 2 you will get
a pop-up to define or specify the
parameters
for volcano log fc the value should be
-1 it is better if you choose minus 1.5
and the value for p adjusted for
significant genes should be 0.05
next to understand the biological
implications of significant genes we
will perform enrichment analysis and
gene set enrichment analysis
based on the enrichment analysis we will
understand what are the important
pathways in which our significant genes
are enriched
similarly we will learn about the
important gene ontology terms that are
significantly associated with the set of
significant genes
when you click on the enrichment
analysis module you will get a pop-up to
set or define the parameters
the value for adjusted p-value threshold
for g or take enrichment will remain
point one
p value correction method would remain
fdr
and the value for adjusted p value
threshold for filtering the dsec2
results before go or keg enrichment will
remain 0.05
similar to the enrichment analysis when
you click on the gsea analysis module
you will get a pop-up to define or set
your parameters
the p adjusted value will be 0.1 p value
correction method would be fdr and the
adjusted p-value threshold for filtering
the desect 2 results before go or kick
enrichment will remain 0.05
now to end the pipeline click on the end
button then name the pipeline and
finally click on the run on clusters to
run the pipeline
once your analysis is complete you are
going to get various plots
the first one would be the volcano plot
and the second one would be the
enrichment and the gse plot also you are
going to get a dsec
all dot text file which is going to tell
you about the differentially expressed
genes in the tabular format
now to learn more about each and every
instruction that we just followed to run
the pipeline and also to analyze the
results and interpret your biological
insights you can visit
lesson number nine on learn dot omics
logic portal
in this lesson you will learn how to
derive biological meaning or annotation
once you identify significant genes and
you will also learn how to perform
interpret gene enrichment analysis on
the server